most people in the world today from
whatever part of the globe they come to
whatever culture they belong most of
them are firm Human Rights important
question for us is to discuss what is
the relationship between faith their
faith and affirmation of Human Rights is
there a way to justify human rights by
appealing to one faith in faith indeed
is there way to justify human rights
without appealing to some sort of faith
and even when we have given
justification for human rights is their
way to motivate respect for human rights
is there a way to prevent from human
rumen rights from being distorted from
being turned into modes of selfishness
so that people are concerned only about
their human rights rather than human
rights of every individual person on the
globe today faith has this partly
ambivalent relationship to human rights
many faiths affirmed human rights and
yet there's a sense that in some faiths
human rights are being denied to certain
form certain groups of people we need to
study and explore this complex
relationship of faith to human rights
ways in which faith can strengthen human
rights but also ways in which faith
maybe sometimes undermines respect for
human rights